Hi, Data2100 students.
Data quality matters. When we talk
about all this data in the world
being produced, we must think about,
but what quality, what qualities does
that data have, and does it have,
as we call it, data quality? Is it
data that we can rely on to drive
business decisions? So let's take a
look at the objectives for today.
In this video, we want to understand
the importance of data and its
ability to mitigate bias. we want to
define and identify data quality
issues. So you'll read about in your
textbook and we'll have a lot of
access to resources regarding accuracy,
completeness, consistency, time
appropriateness, and uniqueness.
So when we talk about things
that are, when we talk
about these five data quality
characteristics, which again
you've read about a lot in your
textbook, we are looking at how
much can we rely on this data
to drive business decisions.
So when we look at how much data is
collected per minute, it is absolutely
overwhelming. And as soon as Domo
is the one that produces this
figure, as soon as this is produced,
it is automatically out of date, right?
Because there's just so much more
data being produced all the time.
So when we look at all this data
being produced all of the time, like
12 million people send an iMessage
every minute of every day. Netflix,
you know, let's think about Slack
users send 148,000 messages.
There is just so much data that we are
producing and that we are consuming
in our daily lives. And we don't
really think about it as data.
And that's what I love about this
world of data analytics is any
industry that you're interested in,
we just started a sports analytics
organization, a student organization
here in our data analytics
and information systems department.
And they are focused in on
sports data. And there is so much
data with sports. If you're at
all interested in sports, the world
of sports analytics is booming.
And it's fascinating. It's cool
to be a part of. So any industry
that you're interested in,
there is data surrounding that.
But before we dive more into
data, I want to talk a little bit
about confirmation bias, and
how we can use data to overcome
confirmation bias. So let's talk
about a story about a car, okay?
So I have driven the
same Honda Civic forever.
I love that car. She is the best.
But I have always dreamed of
buying, and I'm going to call it
just, let's call it a, you know,
fancy, it's not fancy it's really
not that fancy uh let's call
it um well my dog's name is charlie
so let's call it the charlie
mobile all right so charlie
mobile um i really really really
really want this car i've wanted it
forever uh it's nothing necessarily
too fancy but it's also like
a really fun car um but i just
can't get myself to buy this
car so the three things that are
really important to me are safety,
gas mileage, and reliability.
But generally, when I go about and
do some search on this car, when I
look at different reports and things,
this is kind of what the search
results end in. I might be at two
stars on a couple of these, but
really it doesn't rate super highly
on the three things that I care the
most about. Okay, so when I go and
look and I'm I really want this
Charlie mobile, but I care about
these three things. It's like, yeah,
doesn't rank super high on those
things. Really, really fun though.
And so every year I talk myself
out of buying it, but practically
every summer I'm like, I
really want to go buy this car.
But you know what I, I, when I have
done this cycle, it's literally a cycle.
I generally always find
myself then Googling something
like this reasons to buy and
then I insert the car name.
So I then look for reasons
to buy that type of car.
So this is an example of confirmation
bias. I am looking for things to
basically tell me that what I think
is right, that I should go and buy
this car. Even though the three
things that I care the most about,
the data that I'm really looking at
is telling me, yeah, probably not a
good idea. I then go and I say,
okay, but what about, you know, look,
look for reasons to buy this. I want
to confirm these ideas that I have
that this is the right idea. So
that's an example of confirmation
bias, right? I am looking for things
that are going to point me back to
what I already believe to be true,
which is that I should buy this car.
Even though the data, right, those
safety ratings, miles per gallon
ratings, those things are telling
me, yeah, probably not a great idea.
Okay. So then what does, that's
confirmation bias, right? When we're
just looking for things to fuel our
already preconceived ideas or notions.
So how does data, specifically
quality data, how does it help us
overcome this? Well, one way is
things like this, right? That when you
go and buy a car, there are tons of
different, whether it's, you know,
whether it's different reports, different
tests that they've ran
on. There's, you know,
more consumer type of reviews.
There's all sorts of different
websites and organizations like
Car and Driver that help us
rate these cars that give us
some data points. So we can
look at, of course, at the data
and that is what we should do.
So, but we must rely on that data and
that data must have quality, right?
So data quality is the degree to
which a data set can be efficiently
and effectively processed and used.
It is required for data integrity.
It's pretty much the reason the
databases exist and we're going to
talk about that, okay? So I told you
that data drives decision-making,
right? We talked about that in our
initial video, that data drives
decision-making. That because my
the dream car is really scoring
poorly on the three things I care
about I'm going to still hold off
even though my confirmation bias is
like yeah no let's do it let's buy
it right um so data drives decision
making but I'm going to clarify
quality data drives good or informed
decision making so if I'm not
relying on great sources of that data
if that data was collected in ways
that does not maintain quality,
then it's not going to lead me to
good or informed decision making.
So quality data drives good or
informed decision making. We've been
collecting data for centuries, right?
So this is an example. It looks
like of an old ledger, absolutely
gorgeous handwriting. And we can
see here that we are looking at
seemingly an old ledger. So we've
been collecting data for a long time.
But as we have become more and more
of a progressive society in terms
of all of our different IT
infrastructure and data capacities that
we have, we really are focusing in
on the type of quality data that
we have. So do we have data that has
these five data quality characteristics.
So is it accurate data, right?
Was it collected in a way that
it's accurate, okay? Is it complete?
Is there missing data points?
If so, what are those missing
data points? And plot twist,
there's generally always some
sort of missing data. We just have
to learn how to deal with that.
But we do our best to have
complete data sets. Is the data
consistent? If I am measuring
something always in kilometers,
but then I switch it to miles
for a couple of measurements,
that is inconsistent data, right?
So that consistency is true. Am
I using it in a time appropriate
way? Meaning if the data
was, if I'm trying to predict
next year's sales for an
organization, if I use data from 2005,
that's not going to help me
predict next year's sales, right?
But if I use the last 10 years
of data, then it's being used for
the correct purpose and it's time
appropriate in terms of it's not
super latent data collection, or
we're not relying on data that was
collected a long time ago. And
then finally, is it unique, right?
Getting this idea of, we'll talk
about uniqueness with primary and
foreign keys and databases. But
when we think about uniqueness,
we also think, you know, if a
customer walks into my door and they
only make one transaction one day,
then I'm not accidentally tracking
two transactions, right? So is
it unique is really important.
So let's take a look at an example
of dirty data. So here's a quick
example of dirty data. Here I have,
and we're going to talk a lot about
this, but I have a row of data and
then I have columns of data, okay?
So my rows go horizontally
and my columns go
vertically. So just keep that
in mind, rows and columns.
And my rows and columns here,
I'm looking at here in Excel
spreadsheet and we're going to
be working a lot with Excel.
Excel is going to, you know, is
going to hold my data. So this is
holding my data. So this is a
little snapshot of data that we're
looking at. So as we're getting
familiar with what is data, I'm
telling you it's collected all
the time. Here's an example of
data, right? So here, let's say
that this, these are my customers.
Okay. And so here I have ID
number 113. This is my unique
identifier, also called a
primary key, but we'll just call
it a unique identifier. That's
what ID stands for. And I
have a unique identifier, last
name of Smith, first name.
What's their first name? So this
is a completeness issue, right?
I'm missing some data right
here. Pretty important data,
but everything else is maybe
looking okay. Okay. So there's a
completeness issue. Then down
here, as I'm looking at these two
rows again, so let's, again,
we're just looking at rows here.
So I'm looking at these
two rows, rows 115 and 116.
Jenny Roberts, here is
115, and Jenny Robert.
Rut, oh, yikes. So Jenny
Roberts, Jenny Robert.
Well, what's, what's going on
here? These are all the same.
Every other data point,
their city in Denver, their
state in Colorado, their zip
code, their phone number, their
fax number, their email,
their street, everything's the
same except for this one has
an S and this one does not.
So this is a uniqueness issue
more than likely is that we
have this customer tracked
two times but we think it's
the same person. So what do we
do? So then we would have to
do some data cleansing techniques.
We would have to figure
out, is it Jenny Robert or
is it Jenny Roberts? Okay.
Then we have our phone and our
fax. I always question, is fax
used very much? We'll see. And
then I have my email address.
You'll notice right here,
this is a phone number, right?
That's not an email address.
So that's a data quality issue.
I also noticed that this phone
and this fax number are the same
number. So that's a data quality
issue. Okay, that's not true. I'm also
missing my area codes, right, that
435 or whatever it may be. I'm
missing that on my phone and my
fax or 208 or whatever it may be.
And then there's a couple other
things. I'm also missing the rest
of the street address. So this mini
data set that you are having the
opportunity to look at right here,
it is showing some data quality
issues. This is dirty data. So if
we were to put this into a quick
analysis, we would say, oh, I
have four customers. I have four
customers. So I'm claiming that.
I've got four customers. Actually, I
might only have three, according
to the snapshot of this tiny data
set I can look at. So the quality
of the data is so important. Okay,
here's another example.
Here's some different
information regarding, I believe,
some students. So yeah, let's
take a look here. So I'm
looking at a state of residence,
salary, GPA, years to graduate,
major, birth date, and record ID.
So I can see here I have all these
different birth dates. I have all
these different majors. and again my
rows run horizontal and my columns
run vertical okay so my record id
is uniquely identifying each we
can call these records or rows okay
and the birth date is one of my
columns along with the rest of these
are all columns as well so i can
see i have all these different birth
dates i have all these different
majors their years to graduation
their gpa uh salary things like this
so perhaps these are past students
I looked at okay this is how long
it took them to graduate four years
six years things like that and then
maybe this is now their current
salary they've gone off they now live
in a different state and these are
their salaries so this is a sample
this can be an extremely informative
data set to help me understand
what's happening to my students
once they graduate, right? I had a
student and their major was accounting,
so what did they go off and do?
They, you know, moved to Idaho and this
is their salary, okay? Things like that.
Okay, so this is really
important data I'm looking at,
but what type of data quality
issues can we see here?
This is catching my eye, right?
Negative five years to graduation.
Seems like this is a data quality
issue. Birth dates, these seem
like we have some data quality
issues going on here in terms of
we want these to all be in the
same format. So if we are going to
move forward with using this type
of format of July 30th, 1996,
then let's keep using that format,
okay? We're not going to switch
to Saturday, July 3rd, 1999 in
that cell, okay? So this, again,
we're going going to talk a lot
about Excel, but this is like an
Excel spreadsheet worth of data
with rows and columns tracking.
Every row here represents a
student that has graduated.
A couple other, let's see here.
I have my different majors. I'm
trying to see if I notice anything off
the bat. I'm sure there's some
data quality issues here, but so we
have our different majors, our years
to graduation, the negative five.
Looking here at the GPA, if it's
out of a 4.0 scale, this 5.81,
something's going on there.
I have some incomplete salary
data here. And so there's
some things here that I need
to pay attention to regarding
the quality of this data.
So we can continue to point
things out here, but we're
going to move on. But
again, this could be really
insightful data. We just need
to make sure that anytime we're
looking at data, we are
assessing its quality. Okay.
So that's a good introduction to data
quality. And why does data quality
matters? Because as we seek to
overcome our, in this case, our
confirmation bias, right, of doing
things as we've always done it, as you've
read about in your textbook, this
happens a lot in organizations,
is they'll say, oh, well, last year
we spent this amount on marketing.
We're going to do the same amount
this year. But maybe they should not
do that. Maybe the data points to
investing in more of an expensive
marketing campaign. So pointing back
to the data can help us overcome
things like confirmation bias. But
we must have quality data to do so.
And quality data, we
store, to preserve data
quality, we can store them in databases.
Before we do that though, before
we jump into databases, we are
going to orient you to Excel and
small data sets and get you acquainted
with using Excel as we continue
on in the course. Take care.